buckle up because this is going to be a
long one today we're having a look at
the 2010 mathematics extension to hsc
and this is back in the days when the
hsc examinations for extension 2 were
just eight questions so therefore uh
this question we're looking at right now
is the last question
and usually the 15 mark allocation is
sort of distributed across a few
different parts and you'll see different
parts here but the difference is that
all of these parts are really
all connected um we're used to having
part a and part b and part c being
separate when they really want you to
make it um when they want to make it
very obvious to you that it's like are
these are all part of one you know
continuous line of working they'll say
part a and then like one two three or
one two three four if they give you a
really really long one right and
sometimes you know we've talked about
the fact that some questions especially
if there's diagrams or if perhaps it's a
mechanics question where they have to
introduce a lot of a physical situation
and describe it in very explicit terms i
will sometimes collectively say it's
like whoa this is one of those one-pager
questions where the single question
takes an entire page
and this question the question 8 from
the 2010 paper basically says to all
those wow i'm so long because it's a
whole page question and says to all of
them
hold my br because when you have a look
at this it is not just one page as you
scroll through these a b c d they're all
connected and as you keep going you get
to f and it says it continues and you go
to g and then h and then i and then j
there are 10 parts to this question all
15 marks are one integrated whole and if
there are no diagrams and no big slabs
of text it is completely algebraic soup
at least that's the way a lot of people
first look at it and kind of that's
their first impression
so we're going to sort of eat our way
through this chew through it very slowly
um what's the way to eat an elephant
answer one bite at a time and we're
gonna stop at different points to sort
of point out you know why is this
challenging or are there any particular
tricky things that you need to be aware
of however i will say as is often the
case with these massive questions this
question is far more intimidating than
you would actually think even though
there are 10 parts i'm going to put in
an argument that really
and there's a very obvious reason for
this part c the third part is really the
toughest part of this entire question
then everything is sort of well i
hesitate to say it's completely downhill
from there because there's plenty of
tough uh working to do through there but
they scaffold it remarkably for you um
you can see um
questions will often say like you know
hence or otherwise or use part you know
this or that and these questions you
know say if you have a look at part h
it tells you which parts of the earlier
questions that you need to refer to it
says part f and g and then in part i it
says look all the way back to part e it
doesn't expect you to hold all of that
in your working memory so that's a bit
of a relief right
and you can see you know the end part of
this question say i and j
part g
f d they're all a single mark so even
there's a fair amount of work um to
write out um conceptually if you can
follow along what's going on
it's actually not that difficult uh
apart from integration by parts which
you can see called out there in parts b
and c
and even from the notation of part a
aside from integration of my parts
a a skilled and careful extension one
student could navigate their way through
this inequalities might be a bit tricky
but conceptually all the grounding and
foundation are there
so like i said we're going to have a go
through this question there's one last
important thing that you should know
before we start looking at the actual
working which is
why is this question why does it exist
why is it the way that it is
what's the big deal what you know sort
of possessed the hsc exam committee to
devote 15 marks to this one question
well if you have a look all the way down
at the end part j the tenth part the
last one
it says what is the limit as n
approaches infinity of
this particular sum right so it says 1
on k squared and then you're just
counting up the integers for k so it's 1
on 1 squared plus 1 and 2 squared plus 1
on 3 squared
and this problem here of what does this
equal to 1 over 1 squared 1 over 2
squared 1 over 3 squared and then go all
the way to infinity
the sum of the reciprocals of the
squares is actually a famous historical
problem a famous historical maths
problem um and that's kind of what i
think made the exam committee say oh it
would be really cool if we could sneak
this in you know like this actual result
you maybe you've never heard of it
actually has a name you know when things
are important and famous we name them
this problem is called the basil problem
and it's named basil not after like the
herb or a person it's named basil after
a town in switzerland where this problem
was first posed and it's not just like
why is this you know why is this problem
and this you know town uh named after
like you know this problem well or in
reverse rather
the reason is because this problem
played a really important role in
mathematical history when the problem
was first posed
it sort of left mathematicians quite
confused and puzzled all of the
mathematical superstars of the day gave
it a go and were unable to solve it for
over 80 years this problem stood for
almost a century and when i say like
famous mathematicians like really gifted
people i'm talking about people like say
the bernoulli family you might have
known about these guys from physics they
weren't just you know thinking about
physical situations they had to go at
sort of i guess you would classify this
as a number theory problem right which
doesn't have any
immediate apparent physical applications
the bernoullis they kind of tried it and
they came up empty and so a lot of
people said you know when there's a
problem and really smart people have a
go at it it's like is this problem even
solvable there are actually some
problems which we know can't be solved
um which is it's weird a weird idea all
on its own
and the sort of mathematical community
looked at the problem thought maybe it
is one of these you know that you can't
really tackle maybe we should just leave
it to one side
but then like i said 80 years later
along came a young mathematician who
actually boldly said i think i know how
to solve this and um coming up with a
solution
immediately skyrocketed this particular
mathematician to fame and you might know
him because his name was leonard euler
who we now called you know the master of
all mathematicians he just had so many
um insights and discoveries across all
different fields of mathematics not just
like calculus or geometry or number
theory he did it all
and what was amazing about his solution
was a couple of things number one
it was kind of a controversial solution
it used a bunch of techniques that
weren't widely accepted at the time
but he stuck to his guns he came up with
a solution for this problem a specific
value not an approximation and exact
value
and then a few years later he came up
with a solution that was a little more
rigorous you might say and then you know
other mathematicians then sort of took
that on board and say okay fine we
accept it it's rigorous
and then you know after taking that
result it that wasn't the end of it
people didn't say ah okay it's finished
we can walk away from this now. people
took the basil problem and extended it
the
german mathematician bernhard riemann
famously took this result he generalized
it so when you have a look up here you
can see that the powers of these um
denominators or the exponents rather the
indices here are all twos so this is
squaring it right so what
riemann did was he said well what if it
wasn't just squared what about if you
cubed the denominators or raise them to
the fourth power or the fifth and he
named this function what we now call the
riemann zeta function and the riemann
zeta function is the subject of what is
currently one of the most famous
unsolved problems in the world in
mathematics and that's the riemann
hypothesis a lot of people say they've
solved it but we still don't have
something that everyone agrees so it's
kind of weird that the basel problem
this sort of previously unsolved problem
has now given birth to a new unsolved
problem and i guess we're just waiting
for the next euler if there ever will be
such uh such a person so that's kind of
why this means something special right
that you know this incredible piece of
mathematical history actually with the
knowledge that you have access to
through extension 2
as like a 17 year old or 18 year old
person you can you have enough knowledge
and and insight and skill to solve this
incredible histo piece of history okay